a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e dolci ragazzi
l'ultima cosa che avete sentito non era
arabo ma sto pian piano diventando
dislessico cazzo ragazzi ogni mi piace
che mettete a questo video è una parola
in più che si aggiunge al mio
vocabolario credetemi ne ho bisogno
vabbè facciamo il primo zombie shooting
fly e ho sempre desiderato forza cosa
ragazzi non potete capire da quant'è che
aspettava un livello del genere c'è mio
dio doveva arrivare molto poi questo
come fa correre così che lascia una
centrifuga sulle gambe non lo so
comunque sto decisamente amando sto
livello perché cern ha finito perfetto
no sul più bello la testa la testa chi è
rimasta come souvenir bene così devo
dire che ci voleva ragazzi un livello di
zombie era veramente da troppo tempo che
non ne faceva uno gravide coin faccia
con nonno ciak
ma non ho mentirmi so che puoi far ciò
ragazzi ormai è ufficiale appurato che
non lo sa che superman al 100 per c'è
mica come l'ho preso
[Musica]
resti and grande cos'è sto lavorativi
ispirato sai quale devo superare sto
cannone qui così il difficile che è
perfetto ma forse un po è difficile ma
ne sto ancora muovendo non si sa come
ragazzi basta credere in se stessi
ma che cazzo fatto
[Musica]
direi che siamo partiti da dio questo
episodio di happy vis era da secoli che
non riuscivano ste cose concrete
e cos'è sta roba sono partiti break del
[ __ ] york 6 inutile non me ne
frega un cazzo vado avanti anche se mi
dice di andare indietro va bene andiamo
indietro poi diciamo comunque il fatto
che non c'è lì ho chiesto a livello e
già è già un passo avanti perché mi
stanno bombardando e soprattutto perché
non mi sono fatto un cazzo
ma perché per chiedi mi sta tirando
addosso le le nucleari cosi senza motivo
perché è così a casa ho fatto
ragazzi ma neanche chuck norris li fa
una pippa al padre di lui perché fatemi
capire perché mi state facendo plesso
[Musica]
ma il caffè omaggio melo dato uguale
diving questo mi ispira troppo vai col
tuo o mio dio
mamma mia ragazzi perché tu forse
normalmente ormai è troppo mainstream
qualcuno poi mi spiegherà come cazzo
fatto a tuffarmi in piscina a finire su
una sdraio dall'altra parte è comunque
prendisole tranquillo per me non c'è
problema
just free coins cosa vuol dire questo
doveva vado con nonno ciak
vai cos'è cos'è devo prendere piccato
cibo alla forza diva non è difficile
non ci posso credere
c'era una tensione assurda nell'aria ma
ce l'ho fatta non stop disco che cazzo è
il nostro dice mi mettete uno dei
padrini look sexy
escape the box mi mancava anche questo
ragazzi andiamo con il dov'è indiana
vieni qui è brutto stronzo donna modo
non al vetro devi uscire queste cazzo
bravo così esattamente fai vedere che
c'è la testa dura ma togliti e qualcuno
vuole una fetta di culo
devo soltanto spingermi in avanti non è
impossibile get that you the finish line
ragazzi la vedo veramente dura ma ce la
posso fare
adesso come simbolo di vittoria tic ago
in faccia se sei d'accordo che l'homo
ragazzi ma era chiaro sin da avevo
finito quello con chuck norris
figuratevi sono finivo questo ce la
posso fare arrivare al traguardo e cioè
credetemi ce la posso fare
[Musica]
sì sì
ragazzi io ci provo gli stili nei l'isp
iphone faccio sempre cagare ma l'oggi lo
faccio per minchia non sono neanche
riuscito a molti ragazzi fate finta di
non aver visto la scena di prima era era
un allenamento ovviamente c'è già sapevo
di morire
qualcuno non è che voglia di spiegarmi
come cazzo purple rom questo ragazzi
dovrebbe essere tipo 1 sword trova
infatti c'era volevo dire come un
imposti ball è perché ci sono tutte ste
frecce che mi stanno guardando malissimo
io non voglio muovermi ma solo costretto
a farlo voi state calmi e vado mi sporgo
un pochettino avanti proprio un
millimetro e ma allora siete bastardi
credo che se a livello sia
effettivamente 20 volte più difficile
degli impossible ma ce la farò credo
[Musica]
may be moved trovo ragazzi un nuovo
boltro mi mancava questo devo ho vinto
ragazzi ormai non li faccio più tanto
spesso i ball tro perché tanto vinco
sempre cioè non ha senso
i due che faccio fatica cioè non ci
provare gusto ormai c'è io faccio i
livelli [ __ ] non è possibile
adesso senza guardare non mi interessa
dove nei big mac wrecking ball questo
speriamo non ci sia mai l'imbarco e
cazzo è mi sembra roba tipo
pechino teme cazzo kg your girlfriend
guccini la tua ragazza
devo fare [ __ ] che quella non era
effettivamente la mia ragazza mi scusi
ho sbagliato tavolo ragazzi ho sbagliato
a uccidere la ragazza era l'altra ma non
importa
alla fine sono morto ragazzi non muore
questa cioè impossibile
dopo mezz'ora e perdonatemi per prima
non volevo rock swing per fa vigeva il
giordano l'ozio ragazzi posso farcela
vai è di farmi vedere chi sei anche
perché viva la nutella no viva la patata
è così che si ragiona amico mi hai
capito tutto
devo andare su cos'è un tavolo perché
c'è un tavolo per questo non è ma di mio
zio
dammi la birra donna ma che cazzo senso
cioè che questa non è birra e sembra che
ciò però non fa niente spice boy per fa
vj anche questo mi mancava anche perché
corri perché accordi non ho fretta amico
mio
sono caduti perché sono tenuti nei
meloni che questo questo non è uno spy
phone è un meloni phone o vj prova a
superare gli ostacoli più feroci che tu
abbia mai visto o abbona 6 ha esagerato
amico mio
ho visto ostacoli che tu non è la mappa
la gamba la gamba può ancora farcela
se ci fosse la patata fine livello
finiresti è come lo so io questo non
dire bugie si bravi è come ho parlato di
patata guarda caso ci riesci mi sta
prendendo per il culo ragazzi lo fa per
farmi cacciare lo fa per farmi incazzare
world troppo bj by chiusi o ferite
ragazzi faccio l'ultimo è più chiude in
bellezza in prati mio dio
questo è un capo la mario c'è che va dai
fari sul cd che mario vince quest'uomo
mi conosce ragazzi è un mito che i pasti
livelli già posso fare ce la posso ma
[ __ ] no questo voto fini
assolutamente ragazzi non possa arrivare
in un livello del genere dove c'è chi è
mario e pretendere di non ucciderlo con
ho fatto come il freddo si stanno
regolando da solo va bene ho fatto una
strage senza rendermene conto o ragazzi
concludo più l'episodio vogliamo
soltanto dirvi che tra un po intenzione
di fare un livello speciale di happy
with c'è una puntata speciale di happy
wheels che vedrete nei prossimi episodi
non so se nel prossimo va comunque nei
prossimi e spero che vi piacerà a tutti
quanti perché una cosa che mi state
chiedendo da un casino di tempo e niente
non vi spoiler ho nient'altro
come al solito se il video è piaciuto al
sotto un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
tratto nella descrizione se ne siete per
iscritti iscrivetevi invece li vediamo
il prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]